first we discuss the horizontal topic
that has been at the heart of the
discussion since the beginning of
Finland's presidency of the Council the
visit for a long term strategy on
sustainable growth in order to reach
sustainability goals we need stronger
focus on the impact of research on
innovation in order to reach climate
neutrality by 2050 we need substantial
investments in research innovation as
well as rapid deployment of existing
solutions and recording in to the second
policy debate on synergies with horizon
Europe and other new programs we will
agree that better synergies are needed
for the EU to deliver the dialogue with
the relevant stakeholders international
should also be intensified and their
success of synergies at European level
is rooted in cooperation at all levels
Beyond Borders it was agreed that the
research and innovation is crucial for
creating and deploying a new solutions
that promote climate neutrality for
improving the cost efficiency of
existing climate for new solutions for
strengthening Europe's competitiveness
and for contributing to making this
happen in a socially and environmentally
sustainable manner I think that is never
too late and it's never too much to
remind everyone that if we want to find
other economic models alternative
economic models we need more research
and innovation if we want to go from a
linear economy to a circular economy we
need research and innovation and then we
need to scale up those models
you